عبد القادر في ردود الفعل وصف الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايد ان هجوم القدس بانه يمثل
هجوما على العالم المتحدث
الياهو في اتصال عن استعداد واشنطن لتقديم
كل وسائل الدعم المناسبه لحكومه وشعب
اسرائيل خلال الايام المقبله
اسرائيل ووافق على اي ظل فريقه على اتصال
الدائم بنظرهم الاسرائيلي
قال روبرتو نائب هو المندوب الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن الدولي ان واشنطن تعمل للحد من
التوترات في الشرق الاوسط مؤكدا ان وزير
الخارجيه انتونيب لينكين سيتوجه للمنطقه
للتركيز على ذلك ايضا بعد انتهاء جلسه
مغلقه لمجلس الامن بشان الاوضاع في الشرق
الاوسط اعرب عن ادانتي بلاده لهجوم القدس
واسفي هاني مقتل مدنيين
الارهابيه الذي وقع في القدس نرسل تعازينا
للضحايا وعائلاتهم لا يوجد مبرر لهذا
النوع من الارهاب كما ننعى سقوط المدنيين
جراء عمليه مكافحه الارهاب التي قامت بها
اسرائيل في جنين نعمل للحد من التوترات في
المنطقه
كما تعلمون سيسافر الى المنطقه خلال
الاسبوع المقبل وهذا ما سيركز عليه